thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we're currently off the records
and you know why they call it teabagging
why doesn't that look like a ball sack
being dipped in the mouth dipping them
water wait so what came first
the tea bagging or the tea bagging I
think the guys putting balls on people's
faces while they're sleeping came first
no it's because that they named it after
that got it you know there's still water
in here so you go like that
that's why
I've never seen anybody do that that was
really disturbing disturbing
that being said do we have to cut that
no can we file for a sexual harassment
charges we have to bleep that because
you said balls at the beginning no no
it's fine basketball multiplies okay so
we were talking about shut up
we were talking about this topic as we
were doing on our lunch walk right and
not all of us were doing it though not
all of us were doing it only the buff
guys thank you I thought it would be an
interesting thing to discuss and Bart
suggested it and it would be the
hypothetical that if we all right who
are prominently and consistently and
have constantly used the platforms of
social media to build and create Our
Brands and business if we had all of
that reset to zero if that drift was
gone not just our numbers but our
Network and resources if you just had to
start all over hypothetically well I
know what I know now because I learned a
lot from YouTube and Sport it's his
problem you you know everything that you
know now because you learn from all your
mistakes
but we don't have any of the
um access to a Channel with millions of
followers or owners does social media
exist yeah YouTube still exists oh we're
just not famous but we don't have any of
our connections or anything so your own
skill set of what you have now still
exists what would you do
interesting it's like EMP went off but
just on our social media yeah and her
friends yeah yeah and then the MIB stick
hit all of our fans and they forgot that
JK ever existed which frankly happened
I got this idea too because
um I think we're actually really
fortunate at least in this group
that as entrepreneurs a lot of us got
really lucky almost like on our first
and second try whereas a lot of my
friends that have been doing Business
and Entrepreneurship for a long time
they failed like six seven times before
they had something that clicked or did
whatever you know I did a few things
before JK so a lot of people like had to
start from like zero my theory on that
is simply that we were in the right
place the right time because there's
this emerging like [__] thing and
like the tubes like came up so hard that
like we were able to just trickle up
with like all the success of like
PewDiePie and stuff like that and you
know he views us as like scum like he
spits off of his [__] balcony and
like we're like oh thank you PewDiePie
there is water from the skies and the
gods are real and then the funny thing
is PewDiePie came in after us but then
he still is like oh Gene yeah yeah he's
an energy drink I mean just as today's
generation is a bunch of young kids that
are like way more famous than us on Tick
Tock and stuff way more than
yeah good for them too good sense so
considering today's
General especially because most of our
fan base are getting old and they're
dying yeah they're good yeah they're
dying they're not on social they're like
they're not even using their phones
that's why they're bold age
they don't take care of them so I would
say
statistically I'm just reading the demos
after opening up
and then running it and doing that
I was like oh I think I could do
something in food
so you would start back in food if
you're back to zero zero in the bank
accounts with all the knowledge you have
now you would start back in food because
that's what I know right now pretty
intimately and then like
um I could expand from there
but
I think like once you learn one business
you can apply it to the next it's very
similar like the terminology the the way
you think the structure
even if it's like
uh construction like all you got to do
is learn the trade but the system is the
same thing which is like you just need
to make profit in most cases unless
you're a tech company that just needs to
inflate numbers and then like someone
will give you loads of money different
strategy but at least you can understand
everything because once you can run a
business from the bottom up top down
side to side you get the whole picture
if you're working as a
as someone in the machine
then it's difficult to see the whole
picture
so you're really good in your department
and maybe you can do something similar
but then unless you have your own
business it's very difficult to see like
what's what it takes to like from A to Z
so what would you do in the next five
steps
with the knowledge that you have that
may be like the someone that's watching
can go oh [__] I could follow those five
steps too if I didn't have my friends my
connections yeah any following yeah but
I have my skills and your know-how and I
would identify a business that has
morally great owners
meaning like they're fair so if they see
value in people they'll compensate they
don't uh basically they don't skin the
Sheep you know they don't just try to uh
they're they're long-term thinking
also
um I would try to find a business that
has huge potential and I know that I
could make it like 100 x with my
involvement because they're lacking in a
few things like let's say they make this
restaurant is really [__] slept on
it's really good the owners are like
great honest people
um they have a really good team people
that love the business but what's
missing is
maybe they don't know how to do social
media marketing but then they're like
you don't either you [__] zero you
have nothing
but but maybe what they're missing is a
few things right or like maybe they're
so busy cooking that they don't know how
to uh
expand the team or even scale maybe this
one restaurant's extremely good but they
don't know how to make three four five
so then
I would identify where I could fit in
and contribute and help them grow bigger
okay
because it's already moving it's already
like the hard work is done starting from
scratch I think is the hardest where
it's like I have an idea but even if I
did that I can do that too because what
I'll do is I'll start extremely small at
a farmer's market I get like a booth for
like 500 bucks
sell something identify a product that
the area needs or whatever
and I just keep scaling that up
[Music]
that's it thank you that was your Ted
talk thank you I think I'm eating a
rotten fruit jacket but it's old
knowing everything that you've you know
now all the lessons that you've learned
all the Insight that you have from and
you've had uh
like a very inside view of dance for a
long time since caught or even high
school right Not Just Dance Shoemaker
ship and like all kinds of different
things dude he could [__] Cobble away
I'm telling you noodlesmanship oh my God
think about it I mean like what would
you do but then now you don't have you
know that you don't and it's zero in
social media it's a direct to garbage
can noodle that is unrivaled
well what would you do
would you still stay in the same realm
or would you go back to nine to five or
you still going to entrepreneurship I
mean
I think that uh
I think at the end of the day like I
still have uh Talent unlike some of us
um so I could definitely just fall back
like say their names
like I could I could easily just keep on
choreographing and creating yeah you
know what I mean and the crazy thing is
that I could create something and
choreograph and just like I could call
you out to like a top 40 song and let
the let the popularity of that song
drive my notoriety back up you know what
I'm saying and just get that and start
building social media back out there and
the whole thing you stick with dance as
an art well it's because I have like
over 15 years of skill in that thing so
to just throw that away and start in a
brand new skill set I think would also
be like uh not effective and efficient
yeah let alone I'm like not just like
decent at it I like enjoy it you know
what I mean yeah so I think I can and
there's a lot of like very successful
industry dancers and choreographers that
don't necessarily use social media I
think the biggest thing about social
media and what we've been able to use is
to get the notoriety out to let people
know that we do this but even if I uh
well I guess we're [__] am I Men In
Black like wiping everybody's you know
memory of they're like yeah you could
dance but who are you like what if they
say that to you who are you isn't that a
big deal though right yeah they did to
him yeah hypothetical
exactly exactly like I hated them it's
so convenient I picture him at an
audition there's some guy snooty snobby
[__] he kills it and he goes
yeah you could dance but where's your
following huh you know you'll be nothing
in this town in this day and age you
need to have a social media following
you don't have an Instagram you'll never
make it yeah which I never made it off
dance by going to auditions so you're
already wrong nobody named Paul
McCartney will ever be successful
business Anthony Lee who I'm pretty sure
I could just create and I'll probably
just create things that are better than
somebody else is creating in the same
lane or something like that get booked
here get hired there the name will get
passed around in the industry just like
any other like type of Industry like
that and just build my way back up you
know rebuild social media based off like
whatever it is because I'm creating uh
content not like because I'm not
creating a YouTube video I'm creating
like a like a piece of art and then the
medium maybe is like through YouTube and
I think that's different I'm still
capable of creating and it doesn't
necessarily need to rely on like me like
shooting a video for the sake of content
I'm like creating Artistry and that can
get hired or passed around or be put on
a website you know what I mean it
doesn't necessarily need to live on the
platform so I think that's my go-to
because I can always fall back on it
that's who I actually see blow up the
most now there's like people that are
like oh man this little came out of
nowhere like like Alex hermosi or like
thatch or whatever and I'm like well
these [__] actually are experts
in their field and then they got on
Instagram so they've already been doing
something for 20 years and then so they
got on so the minute they dropped the
first piece of content like whoa it's
[__] good talking about like a lot of
us that grew up on it we kind of learned
our [__] on Instagram so you saw the
Wipeout to the black belt but there's
like three third degree Blacklist
jumping on Instagram now which is what
you would do yeah and I think the idea
of like you know things like shoe coblin
or straight to garbage noodle creating
still gives you context it's Unique it's
a unique angle yeah it still gives you
an understanding of how to uh to scale
and do things outside so you're not
limited into one lane you're able to use
it as a vehicle to move around in
different lanes and maximize
opportunities and be effective in
different spaces you know what I'm
saying it's like are you in the food
business or the waste business it's like
there's like a lot of people asking
questions
you're so stupid oh my God I never heard
a direct garbage you're so stupid
Nick it's so dumb I think much like you
I would dive back in yeah because it's
like my whole since my early 20s I've
been developing a skill that would allow
me to coach and teach and that's what I
would go back and especially for
personal training it's like it's a
business that requires pretty low
overhead you know so it's like you don't
need much to start up
all you need is your skill set and
you're selling yourself at the at the
same time so well in your case before
social media you were already in Fitness
and like training and fighting and [__]
yeah I was already I was already doing
that and social media just helped you
scale like get bigger that's literally
what I was too but you said but nobody
knows who you are we're just Social
Security
tears of laughter now that I'm done
talking oh man that makes so much sense
because you're skillful
whoa Nick's on or something hey guys
Nick's opening up hold on meanwhile this
guy's no skills he's just like oh yeah
I'll go into food and I'll just look for
another business who's doing it and then
I'll see where their flaws and maybe do
something has no skill to add himself so
good like I'm I got sales skills dude
yeah you do have sales oh yeah but
that's a skill set that's a great skill
set that you could apply to everything
no but for me I'm notorious I'm
notoriously bad at doing social media so
I've never really liked doing a tourists
for that yeah I'm notoriously bad at it
oh it tells me all the time is this good
like I feel like I'm so bad at it I'm
not I don't it's not natural for me at
all it's like it's more work than
actually working for me but it's cool
that it's you don't even need it for the
business I already have no and honestly
too it's like yeah it's great to have
social media and it's good to like
connect with people but you know most of
my business that I've had is not through
social media it's all through word of
mouth or like other apps where I can get
leads from uh but at the same time it's
like yeah I've just been very thankful
and most of the people that follow me
anyway are like David's fans JK fans who
just like it would have been nothing
without David dude honestly
training people
people ever make it without my following
anyway
the best thing about you honestly is
that you're completely authentic about
not being a [__] [__] oh okay thank
you refreshing I think because when I
when I meet people and they're like what
are you doing I'm like I'm a tuber I'm
[__] sorry I'm tuber scum
everyone judges you immediately if
you're a tumor but then you're kind of
like
and it works for you because you're
honest I'm in a pocket I think I'm gonna
pocket I'm writing coattails with you
guys when you first started when you
first started like
isn't it pretty scary and like how did
you have like the to go like this is
what I want to do and immediately just
kind of have like like did you have
enough clients to cover the bills and
stuff or yeah well at the time I was
supplementing with teaching classes
right when I was at my old job at fight
Academy and it got to a point where I
was like okay well I have enough clients
where you know I was gonna pursue
something else I was going to kind of
get away from the fighting stuff and
just do more Fitness and I was like how
many clients needed to do that to where
you feel it okay this is at that time I
had like 10 to 15 like anywhere within
that range well when I left the gym I
was [__] scared dude I didn't think I
was going to be able to make it the
whole time bro
these guys dude the whole time every
step of the way of any time I did no
idea what's happening I would always be
like there's no way I'm gonna make it
like I'd be doubting myself the whole
way so the fact that I was able to even
keep like I was able to pay all my bills
consistently and to the point where when
I left the gym was when I got engaged
and when I moved in with Tiff so it was
like a big like shift for me you know so
it was it was this is like the most
serious dick's been like hell alone
what the [__] so funny dude sorry I
was like are we trying to do a good
video or no oh stop laughing God damn it
[__] Steve you [__]
Steve set this video on fire nah but the
whole time I didn't think I'd be able to
make it I was like I don't know we'll
just keep doing this I always had backup
plan I was like if I can't make enough
money doing clients I'll [__] get a
job at Trader Joe's I'll [__] work
somewhere else so you're willing to do
whatever it takes right but if you did
you've been very fortunate I feel
honestly so stupidly lucky is ridiculous
if you had to go back to Trader Joe's
with your goal also to go right back to
training though to build that oh yeah
for sure like if if something were to
happen where I couldn't have enough
clients where I could make money just
training people
I'd work at a coffee shop or something
I'd have a supplemental job but you find
a way to make it work I think we should
take a break
[Laughter]
do you feel like in your situation the
quickest way to let people know of what
you do and your skill would be to get
back in the ring because like I feel
like it's like if you start [__]
fools up then it's like oh [__] I need
to learn from that guy yeah potentially
you know what I mean like outside of
social media if you're just in that
industry and you like just [__] like six
people up right in a row but that's not
even like I you don't want to do that
huh nah man I'm I'm definitely not even
when I was competing bro I was like I'm
not a fighter man like I knew it in my
hearts of hearts that I wasn't a fighter
like because you're too much of a
thinker and there's like two trainers in
one like he's strength and conditioning
and fighting okay so like which one do
you actually feel more passionate oh
yeah well I like the variety I like it
all I like that you know and the reason
why I went in this like strength
conditioning and Fitness and Nutrition
was because like I knew
kickboxing and striking was like a kind
of a bottleneck too it was like I could
only get so many clients I was only able
to get a certain population you know so
once I was able to expand then it
allowed me to have a more well-rounded
business so I think making sure I have a
well-rounded business is really
important so I could serve all kinds of
clients real quick real quick though
honestly real quick
um so like Andrew Luck retired from
football making a [__] ton of money
because I think that he is just such an
intelligent person that he's like why
would I put my body through this anymore
I made a [__] money I'm good like for
you like going like I don't need to
fight anymore are you like I'm
resourceful enough I could just I can
train in fighting and I don't I didn't
love it that much yeah I think so I
think I could figure it out and I think
I have been like I I think um
once again I was really lucky but at the
same time it's like
my brain kind of handle it dude I was
getting well you got a concussion I was
getting ko'd left and right here you got
actual concussion didn't you yeah I got
a couple I got a couple David also told
me something that I think has taken more
as a compliment where he said uh he
thinks you're a way better Coach than
you are a fighter too yeah 100 I think
so like the way if you guys ever take
any type of fighting stuff with Nick the
way he breaks things down or even breaks
other Fighters down because to be honest
most Fighters are kind of stupid
um but the way Nick breaks it down it's
actually a very intelligent way of
understanding and learning how like
certain strategies are versus like okay
how come I throw the cross such a
[__] strongest hand man you [__] him
up with that and you're like I don't
quite understand versus like I could do
that too though versus if it's like oh
it's a cross so it's a technical
straight punch so it's the shortest
distance between Like A and B so if
someone throws a hook if you throw the
cross at the exact same time he'll hit
you'll hit him first so you break it
down away you're like oh [__] that's
actually really insulting at all having
somebody be like yo you're a better
teacher than a fighter other people
would take it that but I do in the
industry no I don't think so yeah yeah
well they're not sick I know
I know I'm not made for that stuff bro
yeah I get you that's cool that's
honestly cool no thank you from all the
people that I've trained with I think
Nick's like mentoring style it's so
simple but if you haven't had that
experience in the past it wouldn't like
you wouldn't be able to tell how clear
he makes it like
because for someone that doesn't know
[__] like it's like step one step two
step three it's like that because I know
I'm a really slow learner and I need
everything dumbed down and distilled so
you break it down for yourself well so
it's like I have to break it down for
myself for me to be able to like explain
it properly because I'm I'm a real slow
learner it takes me a while it takes me
a lot of practice to like understand and
know something so I need to like distill
it down because I'm a slow boy that's
what Jackie Chan said he's all like I'm
not like good I just do it a trillion
times because I suck at it or some [__]
like that your boy needs the Reps yeah
that's the kind of uh person I am I
think I just need reps
fear the man that does the one kick a
thousand times versus a 1 000 kicks
first of all that was wrong second while
it's Bruce Lee
yeah what would you do what would I do
this might sound crazy but I think I
would actually stay away from social
media
interesting yeah I think like I think um
when we me and Joe first what
dude that is interesting I didn't expect
that you're such a troll dude no I swear
I didn't like me me and Joe when we
first started it was like the the craft
of doing funny [__] is what I fell in
love with yeah social media to me was
just a way to like get our product
around but then the stuff that's tied in
with it like the fame and stuff I was
like oh I could actually do without this
part because you're you said you're more
introverted anyway yeah so you want to
make material like funny material
artistic or creative but you didn't want
the attention yeah like nowadays when I
talk to a lot of the influencers
nowadays for them it's almost like okay
how do I get a million follow or Channel
and I'll do anything to get there so if
it's Fitness if it's [__] public
disturbance if it's pranks I'll break
check people yeah I'll [__] brake
check I'll do whatever and then to them
once they get to that they're like yes
and then they're like okay how do I hold
on to this for me I'm like oh [__] I
just like funny [__] so it could I could
be a writer for someone I could be
behind the scenes you think you could
have been like a Paul Mooney
yeah it could be someone like that
someone else be the delivery mechanism
and I I just like I like the my favorite
aspect of what we do is the writer's
room Dynamic me too me too when it's
like just a couple of people that I
really care about and we bust up
that's the most amazing part and the the
rest of the fake because I know some
people like it and there's no no like um
no shade thrown at them because that's
what they want for me I actually like a
very private life so like uh the The
Writer's room that'd be super awesome
and that's probably what I would start
off with and then I would say like
because I've also done like Fitness for
a [__] ton of a time I would say if I'm
like if I already if I have to start all
over and I have a wife and a kid like I
do now then the two free things that
everyone has is like sweat and time so I
would probably be a personal trainer too
and just work maybe like 40 60 80 hours
uh a week damn to like get money ASAP
and then live super under means so I can
start building that Avalanche of like uh
monetary momentum you know and I work
your way up to a gym
yeah gym running is is run I mean nice
Joe's learned now running a brick and
mortar is uh
it is a beast man I think we've all
learned a little bit and it's like you
could like walk you can like Oh What a
Beautiful Morning you open the door just
gets slapped in the face you're like
okay I'm gonna stay inside yeah
you know what was crazy like during the
whole cover time there's a um
we were like telling people we're just
trying to follow the rules I don't give
a [__] about politics or anything let's
just follow the rules we finally have
our Gym open we had someone at the front
desk like a guy would come in with no
mask and go hey in L.A you have to put
on a mess so in a couple times after
that they like I'm so sorry but we have
to kick you out because now you're
risking shutting our business down with
the health inspector so they escort uh
escort them out as soon as he was going
out he goes I'm gonna come back and bomb
this place
as soon as they say [__] like that the
manager calls me I'm like what the [__]
like you don't have a manual for [__]
like this you know what I mean so I call
my buddy that's a police officer what
should I do he goes it doesn't matter
what you have to take it seriously yeah
send all your employees home shut down
the gym call the cops get a police
report so it's just like it's like you
wake up oh beautiful sunshine and
someone just comes and kicks in the nuts
out of it yeah
what the [__] is this and then I'm like
okay so like that means can I open
tomorrow like there's all these
decisions you have to make that no one
trains you for so like okay so now I
gotta send the email like what's a good
amount of time is it three days is it a
week you know like you just have to make
[__] up on the spot and I'm like doing
stuff online is way better it is
and why am I in it I don't know I like
getting kicked on a ball
that's what I say yeah because we made
YouTube channels and then now it's it's
like the riskiest business you could do
because you could YouTube Just flips the
switch on you and you're you're done
yeah yeah that's frisky I think if I
started from zero and I had all my
knowledge and everything I would just I
would do this like kind of guilty
pleasure thing I guess I could do it now
but um a lot of things are intimidating
to do when you kind of understand too
much about metrics because then you just
feel like it's a failure too soon but if
I didn't know anything and I had no
media wouldn't matter so then I would
just start
um I would start like with all my
knowledge of old games and all my
knowledge of like music I would start
like a almost like a video game analysis
from the music perspective of old games
of like retro games whoa like a review
Channel or yeah because they have they
have they already have one of those they
already have like just tons of retro
gaming channels and Retro Gaming stuff
uh and then they'll have like you know
video game music stuff but it's very
rare that those things cross where
people are actually really knowledgeable
and good at the games that they know how
to uh emulate the music of usually it's
just musicians or it's just Gamers I
feel like I fit in kind of in a cross I
see and I would like to make something
out of that
love it yeah and just and but again like
I'm like you I don't want to be a face
like I would rather just be a voice
and I don't like I don't like being the
product really but I like making product
yeah yeah
so very very very quickly I would do uh
I kind of want to do it now turn a small
amount of money into a big amount of
money I would just make a little splash
be like hey I'm a crypto tuber what's up
we're gonna turn thousand dollars into
as much money as we turn into in like
wherever you know part of the run that
we're at right and then I would just see
if we can show that happening and people
would follow me based on if that works
or not then I would also do another
thing which I like to do on sometimes
um you know during the middle of the
week when I have crypto Corner stuff
like on Tuesday sometimes like on
Thursday I play a game randomly like
I'll play Pirate game or some [__] on
our patreon so I would just do that
probably I would just take like I'm such
a troll anyway I just play Pirate game
or some [__] and just like post that
because I [__] laugh my ass off so I
can't breathe playing that anyway so
like it's really fun might as well just
[__] do that yeah good content you
wouldn't do any of the comedy realm
stuff
I I think it's it's one of those things
where right now comedy is just so um
it's politicizing yes it's just
completely like okay you watch SNL I was
like man this is kind of like that I
mean look at what happened to uh uh like
like on YouTube dude it's wild and you
just get punished and punished and
punished if you do something like that
so I think unless I was safe in some
kind of place like if I have a wife like
I do and I have to worry about like
money coming in and stuff I don't want
to put myself out there like that like
because I know what my Edge is on Comedy
and I don't want to [__] get have
YouTube come down on me again because
they already come down to me like every
day like they delete all my [__]
constantly I find out another one of my
videos just got deleted like my most
famous video just got deleted wait no
way yeah my sex and public prank on
sexual it's been up for so many years
they just they just found out it exists
damn like 500 million views God
and then yeah they deleted it but then
I'm like I'm answering how do you do a
business on YouTube when they're just
changing the ground under you yeah they
reward you for so long and then they
just change the rules on you and I'm not
bitching I'm just saying like that it's
just hard to make a business nature of
the Beast yeah yeah it's just a whole
different thing like this channel can
disappear tomorrow yeah and then we just
have to try and open up another Channel
and then they'll try to shut that one
down or like we don't know exactly we
don't know who's gonna be in power of
YouTube yeah which moral police of
YouTube now is in control we don't know
that's the thing I'm like hey guys like
you guys know that what satire is right
this is completely satire you think I'm
stuck in a cop's dick in this video
like are you guys [__] bananas like
this is like pornography you can like
come to this you can jerk it to this and
like you a bunch of [__] Christians
thank I'm glad you I'm glad we got a
bunch of Christians apparently who are
in Silicon Valley who are like gauging
all this to the rest of us thank you
very much the funny thing is that one
guy uh some dude I forgot his name he
posted a Bible verse on Twitter after
the Nashville shooting and it said
something like do not have Vengeance I
am the Lord your God and vengeance is
mine very simple that got flagged and
taken down and deleted for uh because it
looked like it was encouraging Vengeance
he was like it's a straight up Bible
verse they're saying wait yeah right
yeah they're saying it's God's exactly
not yours but it got taken down for like
threats of violence
yeah it's like we have to count on
someone with blue hair to like have your
back and like nobody blew her as your
back you know the point where it's down
to a person's opinion you still have to
beat the algo which is crazy yeah that
changes more than the person in charge
yeah because Chad gbt is going to be our
police now
hey bring it the people haven't been
helping me at all
did you monetize me in 2016. bring it
maybe they will be more reasonable yeah
[__] it
oh my God
[Music]